SPEAKER: A huge part
of maintaining security
in the cloud is enforcing
the age-old principle
of least privilege.
Users and service
accounts should only
have the minimum permissions
needed to perform
what they actually need to do.
If you're involved with Identity
and Access Management, or IAM,
how can you be sure that excess
permissions aren't granted?
And as your workload
evolves over time,
how do if the initial set
of permissions assigned
are appropriate or if you
need to make some changes?
That's where Active Assist
Policy Intelligence and IAM
Recommender can help.
Users and applications
access the resources
in your Google Cloud
projects by authenticating
as users or service accounts.
We refer to these
accounts as principals.
The level of access
of each principal
is determined by the permission
specified in the IAM policy.
These permissions are grouped
into distinct IAM roles
to make it easy to assign
access based on different needs.
For example, the Compute
Network Admin role
is a built-in role that grants
full control of Compute Engine
networking resources.
This role includes more
than 400 permissions,
such as all the permissions to
create and manage subnetworks.
The Compute Network User
role, another built-in role
for using, but not managing,
Compute Engine networking
resources, has less than
a hundred permissions.
Any principle with this
role can list and use
existing subnetworks, but not
create, modify, or delete them.
Meanwhile, the Compute
Network Viewer role
grants over a
hundred permissions,
including the permission
for listing health checks.
Each of these roles provides
different levels of access
to the same set of resources.
As you can imagine, managing
many principals and roles
for a collection of resources
can become pretty complex
pretty quickly and might result
in too much or too little
access.
Does the first user actually
need the Compute Network Admin
role?
And is the Compute
Network User role
enough access for
the second user?
Could a malicious
actor take advantage
of over-granted permissions
to cause damage?
Thankfully, the recommendations
from Active Assist Policy
Intelligence can help us
answer questions like these.
Policy Intelligence
is a suite of tools
under the Active Assist
Intelligent Tools category.
These policy
intelligence tools are
designed to help you
make informed decisions
about the IAM policies
on your project
and perform audits and
compliance-related tasks.
Policy Analyzer
helps you understand
who has access to which
Google Cloud resources.
Policy Simulator shows you
how a change to an IAM policy
might impact the
principal's existing
access before the
change is actually made.
Policy Troubleshooter
examines all IAM policies
that apply to a
resource to show you
why a principal might not
have access and the best way
to fix it.
And finally, there's the IAM
Recommender, which offers you
two primary benefits.
First, it identifies
the principals
that might have excess
permissions granted to them.
The Recommender spots those
excess permissions and uses
machine learning to
predict future usage.
This information is saved
as Policy Insights for you
to understand your policy
usage at the project, folder,
or organization level.
The excess permissions
are identified
by comparing the permissions
that each principal has used
in the past 90 days with
the total permissions
that that principal has.
Second, the IAM Recommender
assesses each role
granted to a
principal to determine
if there's a better fit, while
optimizing for least privilege.
These suggestions could be
for a more appropriate role,
multiple roles, or remove
all the permissions together.
Suggested roles might
include built-in roles,
like the ones that we've
mentioned earlier, or custom
roles.
Custom roles can include any
combination of permissions
so there's a lot
of ways that you
can control the
roles and permissions
that your principals have.
Let's take a look at what
the IAM Recommender looks
like from the Cloud Console.
For this demonstration, I have
the IAM Recommender Admin role
to view and manage the IAM
recommendations and the Project
IAM Admin role so that I can
update the project IAM policy
with those recommendations.
Let's take a look
at the IAM and Admin
page, where the IAM policies
for our project, folder,
and organizations are managed.
This view is for our
project, where we've got
some recommendations available.
At the top, we'll find a
banner with some priority
recommendations.
We can click here to add a
filter to our table below.
The light bulb icon in the
Security Insights column
means that our ML models have
identified a recommendation
for that principal.
For example, this
particular service account
has the Editor role
assigned to it,
which is a role with
a lot of permissions,
as you can see here.
The recommendation here is
to replace the Editor role
with the Storage Object Admin
role for this principal.
On the right are the
individual permissions
that will be removed if
making the recommended change.
We can accept the recommendation
here by clicking Apply.
That recommendation will now
appear on the Recommendations
History page.
Here's where we can see how
many recommendations have
been applied and
what the details are.
When we select the
recommendation,
there's a summary of
the change, including
the list of the permissions
that we saw before.
If anything were
to come up and we
would need to undo
the change, we
can click Revert to
restore the permissions.
For another view of our
IAM recommendations,
we can head over to the
Recommendations Hub.
Since we only have the
IAM Recommendation Admin
role assigned, those
are the only kinds
of recommendations that
will show up on this screen.
Clicking View All shows us
all of the recommendations
matching this category.
And selecting one of
those recommendations
will give us additional details.
Just as before, we
can review the changes
the recommendation
suggests, including
the permission for
the current role
and the permissions for the
recommended replacement role.
If our IAM policies are managed
with the infrastructure-as-code
solution Terraform, we
would click Use Terraform
to see the proposed change as
a code snippet in Terraform
configuration.
Otherwise, we can just click
Apply to update the project IAM
policy with the role change.
The IAM Recommender helps you
improve your security posture
on Google Cloud, focusing on
the principle of least privilege
with a set of machine-learning
powered analyses.
We saw what these
recommendations look
like from the Google
Cloud Console,
but you can also
access and manage them
through the API and Google
Cloud Command Line interface.
You can find links
in the description
for more information
on policy intelligence
and using the IAM Recommender
as part of the Active Assist
portfolio.
Don't forget about
the Recommendation
Hub, where you can see all sorts
of helpful recommendations.
Stay tuned for the next video,
where we'll look at some ways
that you can take
these recommendations
and apply them at scale.
See you there.